I must uh maybe go round you're right
where I work but I do no problem with
that did you notice mom like a
song for that dick I'm like this funny
support chunk but I did sleep on the
street be a damn bum for that my grandma
purse for that day and put me in a
hearse for that my mother did to
Cleveland today
yeah be call me old-fashioned but they
come across kind of desperate internet
everyone's doing their version of game
over readings for that D freestyle and
if you think the ladies are horny you
should hear the fellas I'm pacing strike
frivolously you could catch me at the
ultra maker wife Robert chase but that
puts commit a homicide I'm a loose awake
but they're all talk most guys just text
you up for that listen I don't
want to dwell on the differences between
our private parts the country is divided
enough meanwhile bud wolves are over
here like what do I have to do I give up
upon don't vet amoenus don't even have
your white bat anus I believe my spouse
for that anus take a loss on my house
for that anus but your cheeks for that
anus I claimed responsibility for wet
house leak for that anus get brain
freeze for that anus I'll take a need
for that anus
get a look far to me for that anus not
even join Scientology for that anus I
drop cargo short for that anus I'm
living a pillow fought for that anus
Sheldon for that anus go to tech school
learn a trade like welding that anus
cut-rate the first overall pick for that
anus dick put that ain't it well maybe I
should have been more specific I was
talking about lady anus
[Applause]
[Music]